[Music]
valuetainment giving values contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we gain no
value to haters how they run homie look
what i become i'm the i'm the one
[Music]
when you got david this sets the tone i
like it listen tom we miss you i gotta
tell you man it's been a minute since uh
obviously i saw you last week in l.a
yeah but we uh miss you
uh we are back we haven't done a podcast
for a week we you know a bunch of things
going on in l.a but today we have a
special one for you folks let me tell
you why
if you've ever seen the movie deadpool
okay i want you to think about if you've
ever seen a movie deadpool imagine the
real life
person
of playing deadpool but this is a real
life type of guy that you're talking
about
badass military ranger i think five
tours
uh a rapper one of his uh songs was it
was a billboard number 36 youtube
channel with a million and a half
subscribers
makes viral videos he came out of the
closet one day telling his parents he's
a conservative just a lot of different
things very interesting dynamic funny
intense badass veteran special guest
matt best uh co-founder of uh black
rifle coffee it's good to have you on
thank you so much for having me on that
was i feel amped up after that intro
thank you so much yes
we're excited about having you on it's
uh you know the whole thing with uh
podcasting man when you do it and you're
having fun you want to do more of it and
then we got interesting characters like
you that come on it makes it even more
exciting but tom uh last week we were in
la i gotta tell you what happened in l.a
which was kind of weird you know how you
went to new york and you said wow new
york's much better and etc etc right
that's what you were talking about about
a month ago and by the way
i talked to you tom then i think you
said you went to new york and it was
great oh my god we went we took the
family we went we went to dc first and
then we went to new york city and you
know the thing is you're so programmed
now to believe the media or you're just
so susceptible to the crap that they
feed on you so you think it's chaos yeah
it couldn't have been better i thought
new york was better than it was the last
time it was there pre-pandemic dc was
incredible yeah so don't believe the
hype man these cities are open but i
mean just to see what you have to say
about los angeles are you gonna announce
that you're moving to portland i think
the audience you want to do it now one
state at a time okay until i get to
florida well let me tell you
yeah he might he would make a great
leader tom what do you think about that
that's pretty that's a good thing on
your resume
we consider it we had a similar i guess
uh conversation last time we were in la
the first time we were there 2020 yeah
we went literally looking for the
homeless we didn't have to look hard was
it that bad though when you and i first
time how about the last time you and i
were not bad at all let me explain to
you what happened this year okay let me
explain to what happened last time
so i lived in granada hill so we went
and we kind of went back on all the
offices and buildings and everything
that i was leasing and
uh granada hills filled with
homelessness everywhere couldn't believe
it glendale homelessness lower
this time glendale was like a three
granada hills was a seven you ready
let me put it to you this way beverly
hills was a 10. get out of here
you know what you know how you say this
it sounds like you're you know how it's
like you're over hyping it up come on i
can't believe you're saying this so i go
to
a new restaurant in beverly hills called
catch okay
and it's a steak restaurant our friend
kevin took us remember i told you the
story about catch on a podcast what's
that that remember my friend had his car
set on fire in front of his business on
la cienega is that cat it was right
across the street from catch and they
couldn't open catch for the longest time
because some homeless had pitched a tent
and they couldn't get rid of them tyler
i'm sending you this clip if you can
show it
uh if you can pull this up and show this
uh uh so so this is this is beverly
hills right across from sls what is sls
hotel supposed to be low end is it like
a competitor motel six or what
the homeless guy built a tree house
across from sls i mean that's pretty
creative if you think about it that's
impressive
he turned it into an
airbnb enterprising young man do you
have the clip or no title right just
give me one second okay so i'm i'm
pulling up in beverly hills we're going
you're assuming like if there is a city
that represents america that cannot be
but think about people from look at this
right here press play so that building
that you're looking at across is sls
you see all of that sit up right there
homeless
there's even a treehouse that's in front
of sls hotel
in beverly hills
i could not believe if there was a city
that i thought would not have any of it
it's beverly hills but uh so i was going
hoping i can come back with a story like
you had about new york i don't have that
story about l.a
and uh uh it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens so what changed because
maybe we just went to different
neighborhoods we were in venice we were
expecting to see all [ __ ] and this
literally happened and it wasn't bad
it's not at all oh the last time you
were there yeah but but why would you
allow like listen if we're in florida
and it's not even like [ __ ] on
california you can't allow beverly hills
to look like that but it is what i have
i'm born and raised in california so i'm
embarrassing my state a little bit so
well
the crime in beverly hills is off the
charts too i mean that people anybody
that goes to beverly hills for dinner
now they will not wear their nice
jewelry because they can be followed
home it's it's a big deal this stuff
happens like all the time yeah guys
everybody's dming me saying hey take
that jewelry off take that watch off you
don't want to be seen walking across in
the streets with i'm like what are you
talking about so you think propaganda
people are talking a lot about it and
then you're like no maybe it's really
happening gas prices were 669 by the way
so yeah 669 is legit oh great
for the audience that doesn't know matt
do you mind taking a minute and give
them your background you know how you
guys came about with black rifle coffee
ranger for the audience that doesn't
know sure sure um the reader's digest
version is essentially uh born and
raised in santa barbara california i
come from a very long lineage of
military history all my great uncles
served in world war ii my dad's uh
marine in vietnam my two brothers served
in the invasion of rock actually it's in
my book but they uh they were supposed
to graduate september 11 2001 so it was
a kind of compelling story about how
that kind of the day they were supposed
to graduate changed the course of their
lives forever and kind of probably my
life as well because i'll give it to the
marines they look good in those dress
blue uniforms and when i saw them
walking up there saying i want to serve
my country and so
joined the military at 17 went on to
serve and second ranger battalion um did
five tours with them got out hated my
life as a civilian actually moved to los
angeles and
for me it was just the politics and then
the age
group that i was in at you know 22 years
was just so
different than where i had been
conditioned to be in my life and so i
went to rejoin the military but actually
got a job contracting in the
intelligence community so i did that for
about five and a half years
and that was kind of the way that i
helped fund a lot of my businesses early
on was essentially taking the capital
from deploying um segmenting times when
i was home and then just kind of
knocking stuff out day by day so it was
a lot of like risk management because i
was making a decent six figure gear
salary working for um the organization i
was working for and i just applied that
and worked my butt off put myself
through college and the rest has kind of
been history
matt question you know a lot of times
you you you'll go there's a friend in
dallas ballon is his last name who they
run this military thing with another guy
that we went to their event there was a
bunch of guys rangers delta special
forces you know paratroop all them like
the badass guys in the marketplace in
the military what do you think is
the biggest transition from guys who
made it here in the military to coming
into civilian and making it because you
know it's kind of like well if you can
make in the military you work so hard
camaraderie team leadership
shouldn't you come out and kill it in
you know in the private free enterprise
because it should be an easy transition
what is the biggest challenge to
transition from
you're here protecting saving lives on
the front line you're getting shot up
seeing people you're seeing some
difficult things i mean chaos non-stop
to transition into civilian i think
there's a lot of job skills obviously
like if you're if you're a team leader
in an infantry unit and you're making
dynamic decisions while getting shot at
you you already have such a leadership
sensibility about you that absolutely
applies the civilian sector for me
it was the the cultural change from the
military right because all of a sudden
i had to deal with [ __ ] feelings and
that's the truth whereas when i'm
overseas and you're working with a very
professional team you know we we have
the most edgy jokes to each other but we
all know that you we got each other's
backs and there and for me coming into
the civilian sector that was the hardest
part because all of a sudden i had to
like worry about a pronoun like straight
up and and for me it really messed with
my head and it was re the whole reason i
went back overseas because i wanted to
be around people like me that could make
jokes make a be a little reverent and
then
that kind of metabolized into me saying
hey i'm gonna start my own businesses
because i can choose culturally who's a
part of that and i want to work with fun
exciting educated people that want to
crush life i don't want to work with
people that want to be victims and
that's what i found a lot in the
civilian sector and i'm not paying that
for everybody i'm just simply saying
corporate america has been conditioned
like that or especially the last 10
years it's gotten so much worse so if we
have the opportunity to create a culture
and hire veterans that believe in the
stuff we believe in and give them
you know
a safe space in in a way of in
irreverent terms kind of the opposite of
a space space where people can wear
their tattoos say the f word like let's
just get work done and treat people well
and
do you ask that in the interview process
like or do you are you more i'm actually
really curious because you guys have
built a very very successful brand
company i mean you guys are killing it
it's not a small thing that you guys are
building you guys are done a great job
with the company so is it you use a
recruiting firm that specifically
focuses on talent and culture and you
tell them these are the five things
we're looking for if you come here or do
you guys in the interview process
specifically ask certain questions that
filters out people that maybe won't fit
your culture what's that process yeah i
think it always starts with the top
right so you have the chro or whoever
you're you know head of human resources
is like that comes from the founders and
the executive staff as far as hey these
are the things and the attributes that
we want in someone and it's almost like
uh back in the intelligence community
rather have someone has a tssci
clearance and then train them how to do
a profession because the clearance is
the hardest part the culture in business
for me is the hardest part once you see
someone and you know okay they might not
have the exact skill set that we need
quite yet but we can put a professional
development plan together and then
honestly i like that because especially
if they're a veteran we're providing
them a structure to succeed learn a new
skill and they already have their
leadership experience they have the
culture experience now it's just a
matter of like how do i roast coffee
that's a that's a pretty easy skill and
we're giving them a new skill so
it's all in i think the format of who
you're looking for and and the culture
aspect of of the employee side is is a
very large thing for me at least got it
so it's up front so what if i'm if i'm
going through the interview process i'm
already gonna know what it's gonna
entail to be part of black rifle coffee
yeah and let's be honest a lot of it and
maybe doesn't even need to come from us
because if you look at the company and
you go on and look at the videos and you
watch coming out as a conservative you
referenced that earlier
you have a pretty good indicator of what
my values are and and what the company's
values are so
you either like it you don't know you
know a lot of people don't like it and
they don't come work for it have you
ever had people that don't agree with
your values that work with you guys and
we're successful uh i'm sure yeah i mean
okay they probably work out about it a
little bit how big are you guys at this
point how big is
employees a thousand employees got about
50 veteran high rate in that too no [ __ ]
50
yeah props to you right around there
first of all thank you for your service
and thank you for hiring
vets the way you are fifty percent
yeah i mean that's what we set out to do
and we're not done i mean this is just
the start to be honest with you so
what's the vision what's the grand
vision what are we gonna be doing all of
us gonna be drinking coffee one day
hopefully i saw some other coffee back
there in the green room i had to change
that out
this is weak bro this is not your coffee
that's right i'm not drinking it
i was expecting maybe a gift or
something bro i don't just well it's not
in the mail i promise okay
um no i mean we made a promise to her
customer base we're gonna hire 10 000
veterans years ago and um that has been
at the forefront of our of our our
journey this entire time and you start
to see that a lot more with some of the
brick and mortar um locations opening
and a lot of other the strategic
partnerships that we're we're doing like
partnering with dallas cowboys stuff
like that so it's it's always who loves
you who hates you who loves black rifle
coffee who hates black rifle coffee i
mean a lot of people love us and a lot
of people hate us you know we've been in
that we've been in a culture war a few
times during it um so we're we're not
shy to uh
yeah a little a little hate in the
internet but i'm okay with it yeah it is
what it is speaking of haters you guys
since uh whatever deal you
put together with the dallas cowboys
made a lot of news yeah what was that
what was the drama with all that
especially with the the recent string of
mass shootings or school shootings that
was kind of in the news
it's like it's a it's an emotional
position from woke media in my opinion
because when i look at this and i look i
look at it like battle space back in the
military of like who's taking shots and
why are they taking shots well
they're trying to rip away like people
that just love america and that's where
i started because it's america's team in
america's coffee so when a lot of people
somehow based off of us having black
rifle coffee in our company's name tried
to use that and sensationalize that into
saying that somehow it was distasteful
because a national tragedy happened and
then a football company and a coffee
company are partnering
i don't understand was it the timing is
that what it was yeah but i mean when is
but that was months and months ahead
right so it is what it is if people want
to get offended at that hey it is yeah i
think i think you need to be
congratulated for doing a deal with
jerry jones that's that's the epitome i
mean that is phenomenal that's going to
pay a huge benefit let me ask you this
matt um you're not that far removed from
the military what are people telling you
as far as the walkification of the
military is that real i mean have are
they changing
yeah i mean we we've talked about this
over the years it seems from a lot of my
friends um not every unit but there are
specific units and the cultures that
have been changing because when you have
a lot more progressive leadership that
comes into the white house and and other
portions of the country their influence
over generals and admirals and name the
brass that top down right top down comes
from culture and
yeah i
i don't know this whole like mandatory
vaccination thing in the military i mean
it seems as we're just trying to create
a weak force which is like the opposite
of being a war fighter like it's okay to
have tattoos and you're going out on
target with your friends to
kill or capture high-value targets like
that's a real job and it's you need
people that signed up for that i'm
trying to be very uh
casual with my statements there but
the whole purpose of being in the
military is is to fight wars and win
them but i think man's men are making a
big comeback i think it's coming back
and i think people are
uh sitting around and saying what the
hell are you talking about by the way
you know who's going to help man's men
make a comeback women
it's going to be where a lot of like you
had you had a you had a girl on on your
podcast was like listen this is what i'm
looking for for man i want to be able to
do this i want a man that does this
where they're looking for more alphas
of men who are willing to step up and
take the lead rather than being
you know pansies walking around thinking
they have to please everybody and and i
think it is making a comeback so i don't
think that's going to slow down
by the way just out of curiosity what
was the the issue with written house
what happened with the shirt that was
worn if you can talk about that a little
bit because there was a little bit of
controversy with that
yeah i mean we got we got kind of thrown
in the center of that i mean the start
of it was um
and i it's weird that i have to say this
so much but going into that um i always
when you watch that video for me kyle
rittenhouse defended himself with a
firearm legally and i've been a huge
second amendment um proponent my entire
life i mean i'm one of the like og guys
on youtube that started making comedy
videos um well when the shirt came out
it was a huge mix up with like kind of a
sponsorship essentially and
um
it was
pretty much said that we'd sponsored him
and we didn't sponsor him and so when we
put a statement out saying we didn't
sponsor him people took that as we don't
support him drastically two different
things um and also like we had us we had
kind of a weak response to be honest
with you we we were caught off guard and
we were we kind of [ __ ] it up to be
honest with you like oh no [ __ ] yeah
like okay i think i think uh there
wasn't clear and concise like this is
what we believe it was scattered
information and then people ran with the
false narrative and you know when you
look back at certain things like that
like i'm not a pr expert man i was
carrying a gun professionally like eight
years ago so um
but it is what it is and i think most
people see now especially even after the
company went public we have not veered
from anything that we've ever done like
at the time where most people might
change their brand position we're going
hard in the paint with their support for
second amendment i mean i just did a
great podcast i thought with the
firearms policy coalition who i think is
the leader in second amendment um
the lawsuits and everything they do to
protect the second amendment so we're
out there doing what we believe in and
i'm a constitutionalist and
most people know that but question for
you sure
in that moment because i remember one
time you know media matters came after
me and daily beast came after me we were
having an event i think with
uh uh uh
kobe bryant the late kobe bryant and
president bush and jordan peterson we
put you know six that you were at this
event right six thousand people were put
in the room and it's it's an incredible
event phenomenal event that we had next
thing you know patrick bet david this
i'm like what the hell is going on so we
came back and we called them up and we
addressed them we handled we had a
lengthy call i was just coming back on a
flight the
incentive trip we had with our guys but
we didn't have a publicist at the time
we didn't have a you know a big sunshine
sax in new york saying here's how you
handle it first time when you say this
this is the script
when that happened to you guys did you
have somebody that was kind of directing
you guys were you took the council from
them or was it more
here's how we're reacting to this crisis
for me it was more i was just so taken
back that people on like our side would
be like that we went woke and we're not
we're anti-2a i was i was actually more
confused than anything
um and part of that too is that i didn't
really realize the importance of that
situation for the second amendment
whereas if he would have been found
guilty
what that would have done for case law
didn't know that until probably a couple
months i sent out a lawyer and a friend
he was like this is why this specific
instance matters so much i went oh
i got it but then also right i look in
the sense of
i'm a veteran owned and operated coffee
company that puts veterans first and i
like i'm a huge gun guy personally and
so like i didn't necessarily know why
the company had to make a statement in
in that situation was it was just very
confusing at the time i feel like and so
i think to your point um you make
mistakes you learn from them and all you
can do is be exactly who you are and
stay authentic and i think we've done
exactly that how
just again just to finish this up i want
to move on from this topic but if if you
like the next time around something like
this happen what's going to be the
different approach is there like a new
sys because we created a system for
ourselves because if you don't know how
to deal with the immediate they're going
to bully you and they're not going to
stop because they'll keep picking at you
what is the new approach that you guys
are planning on taking if something like
this happens well in our initial
statement we said we believe in the
judicial system pretty much it was like
verbatim that um i don't want to say
verbatim because i don't speak out turn
but it was we like we it was implied
that we were fully supporting kyle and
we believe he was going to be found
innocent
but there was still gray area in there
so probably ford i'm going to be so
clear and concise with my statements
because obviously anybody can take a uh
i mean we see the news that has done
that so many times sister over the years
they take an interview they misplaced
the statement and they make you look
like an [ __ ] so you know what it
almost is here's here's the craziest
thing
uh
what it almost is and you hear this over
and over and over again until it happens
to you
man you know to apologize or not to
apologize right to to
bow down or to say listen this is what
we stand for the guy has the freedom to
wear that shirt this is what he supports
did we ask him to wear that shirt the
guy chose to wear that shirt how come
you don't call people the next time
there's a shooting and the guys wearing
nike akanaki doesn't get called out for
that how come you know puma come whoever
it is i don't know who wears puma but
how come these other guys don't get
called out for that and but but this
specific area is because of hey this is
what you stand for you're conservative
boom let's go after this so
you know it's it's almost if you are
specifically if you're conservative
it backfires if you try to
play the diplomatic game they will keep
bullying you over and
yeah plus there's no doubt where you
guys stand and you're very articulate so
you don't really make mistakes if a
microphone goes in front of you so i
think you have that as an advantage i
think people are getting tired of the
apologies i think
a few people are gonna we're just
exhausted from it don't you think a few
people are just going like you you watch
some of these commentators right now
that oh and comedians and you see what
happened to dave chappelle in
minneapolis i'm not sure if you guys
talked about that where show got
canceled last week at first avenue but i
think people are just exhausted of
apologizing and hearing apologies all
the time like
who has the time to be offended by
everything like i if i said something
that offended a lot of people i honestly
wouldn't care i mean like why would i
want to go out of my way to apologize to
somebody in topeka that i've never met
before when i i laugh on that too
because you know i i don't speak
a lot about politics i don't know as
much as you guys do but i have obviously
my opinions but um i'm like not a
political pundit you know i'm like a
knuckle dragger that carried a gun for
10 years and then
does stupid comedy on youtube and
somehow started a business so
for people to over believe that i i'm
like the smartest guy in the room is is
the wrong thing i'm just putting one
foot in front of the other and trying to
do what i could do so but you but you
you've created a thousand jobs
you've taken
500 vets that you've given them a job so
i remember when you go through the ets
process and you're going through not not
maps what is the other one that you're
kind of going through it's like six
weeks
and uh hey you know here's the job
opportunity you know i was going to be a
cop at fort lauderdale mall they offered
me 36 grand and i'm living in la i'm
from l.a i'm from granada hills i'm like
am i going to go take this job at the
fort lauderdale we're building a new
mall would you like to be a cop here
literally thirty six thousand dollar
year salary and okay you can go do this
you can go work with post office if you
take the test you get an additional ten
points you can be a firefighter but
there's a freeze in la that whole
process when you're going out of it it's
like you're going from hardcore routine
hardcore formation hardcore structure
tonight you're a civilian and in the
military
that transition
you know i think you talk about
transition where anything in life
anytime you're transitioning that's not
a
that's not easy you know when people go
through a transition process so for you
to help currently i'm sure you guys have
hired more than 500 vets but currently
to have 500 active vets that are working
with you guys
you know you're you're helping and await
the government you're doing government's
job
without taxpayers needing to support
those vets you're giving them a job but
they're able to have dignity and pride
in the work that they're doing and i
think that needs to be celebrated and
they need to say thank you to you for
what you guys have been doing rather
than the other way around well we're
stoked because um the dod and a lot of
leadership specifically in some of these
old soft units are making really good
decisions i think as far as when people
are getting out so we've been working
with the dod like with skill bridge
programs and it's something that i wish
could have happened to me but probably
good it didn't is when about six months
before someone's getting out of the
military they'll actually pay their the
dod will pay their military salary they
come and work for us for six months and
intern within the company and then from
there a lot of the time more than not
we'll hire them on as a direct hire
right there because they they got to
learn and and if not then they at least
get to see and taste what it feels like
to be in the civilian sector and more of
like our realm so if they go somewhere
else so it's helping with that
transition stuff and and we've we've had
quite a few of those coming through the
doors lately and it's it's a really rad
program and how long have they been
doing that that transition
um specifically dod skill bridge stuff
i'm not sure how long that program's
existed with us i think we got in
involved about two years ago with that
that's cool that's great go ahead here's
my question for you bro um i mean you're
a patriot who served our country and i
know your book was thank you for my
service so um thank you for your service
your patriots who served our country now
you're serving coffee to americans so
respect but
my question because i think only seven
percent of living americans have served
in the military right okay i didn't
serve in the military i've actually been
around more military people since
joining valuetainment hanging with pat
and sapala and eric and chris like some
of my very closest good friends but a
lot of americans don't have experience
with military i think
less than one percent point
one percent are active in the military
so
what i'm trying to understand is mostly
for people watching this i assume 90
something percent people have never
served in the military
i want to understand the the culture a
little bit better because if you're not
around it you don't get it you don't get
why people in the military love 2a so
much right what the brotherhood is what
the pat always talks about the
camaraderie so i mean you're hiring
veterans you're around these people
you're empowering these people
what i understand is what is it like why
does the military obviously
are as proponents of the second
amendment why what is it about the
military that people just don't
understand the brotherhood of the
military well a lot a lot of uh
most people that i that were war
fighters in in in infantry special
operations tend to be proponents of the
second amendment because when you're
deployed like black rifle coffee black
rifle that's a life-saving equipment
that's life-saving tool
everywhere you go i slept with that
thing i went to ciao with it you know
that is the difference between
saving my own life and my teammates life
and not being very proficient with it
and it's a tool
and a lot of this like the civilian side
that's never touched a gun right you're
scared of what you don't know but that's
what we did we hand it every day we know
how to safe handle it and
um i mean i carry a gun every single day
in texas because i mean
if something happens and and i'm not to
get too far into it but like when people
oh more guns uh we'll fix the gun
problem we just saw it happen in indiana
when an active shooter shot i think two
or three people and a concealed carry
license holder shot the guy and saved
countless lives so for me that's the
whole reason it's a it's a tool and it's
a tool of safety and
that comes from i think a lot of us just
carrying those in in our background but
yeah to the culture side of the military
man it was just
we lived in a tent together for like
months upon months and so you just kind
of have this bond that never changes i
had
the the opportunity to see my two best
friends i've known for 18 years um went
to basic training airborne
rip um ranger school war um so we gotta
drink whiskey and tell war stories uh
this weekend so that's cool it's it's i
haven't talked to them in months and we
just pick it up right where we left off
and something like that i'm very blessed
to be part of in your videos um because
it's not all glory it's not all
glorified i mean in your videos some of
your best friends are in your videos
half of them have freaking no legs bro
or missing an arm like i'm like holy
[ __ ] this guy's doing comedy he's doing
satire he's being funny but at the same
time just looking at the images guys are
missing limbs how do you grapple with
the the humor of life but also some of
the
the downs of being in the military
i can't speak for you know
all amputees or anybody i'm not an
amputee so i can't say anything but i
will say like most of my friends who are
missing limbs they want to be treated
like they're human
and i think a lot of times with visible
war injuries people treat them
differently and they just want to be a
part of the crew and that's why you see
a lot of um the jokes that we make where
i think crispy uh omar avila he he rolls
the uh the lawnmower and pretends to
chop his leg off and and then you know
stuff like that so it's it's kind of
humor through horror kind of vibe where
we just have to laugh about it because
you can't change what happened you can
only change what hopefully will happen
do these guys have regrets missing limbs
or they do they wish they never went to
the military did they double down and
say it was the best decision of my life
i'm trying to understand the mindset
especially when you lose limbs for your
country i would i would say that we're
we should be very thankful that such men
and women exist that can lose limbs and
say i'm happy and i would do it over in
a heartbeat um one of my mentors clint
trial um
absolute badass dude um over 20 years in
the military last deployment got both
his legs blown off and um he works with
us now and he's been like a mentor i sit
down talk this guy
i just want to go like do push you know
swing a kettlebell because his
perspective on life through all the
tragedy that he's had is just absolutely
brilliant and i wish more people would
sit down over a cup of coffee and listen
to a gentleman like pat all the time
talks about like i feel like that's like
your fondest memories of life is your
time in the military and the camaraderie
and you i mean you've had friends come
in here yeah on the show and you know be
a part of this i mean what's your take
on that listen i mean he but he's at a
different level you got five you know
you're talking about
he made it to the pinnacle of experience
and what you do with the military ring
you know to do what he did but the main
word you'll hear from almost everybody
in the military is the c word it's
camaraderie that camaraderie and by the
way here's the part
if you have thin skin you're not going
to make in the military because the
jokes
if if ten percent of the jokes were seen
in the public like you know yeah you
know military they can't do vlogs
because the youtube channel would be
shut down yeah like they would offend
everybody the jokes are so direct and
painful
that you're either going to be able to
handle or you're going to say i got to
transfer to a different unit so it
toughened you up you built a friends
relationships and you see anyone like
the other day one of my guys sent me a
message klingerman klingerman
this guy was funny he was a guy that
played football in ohio so we'd go to
bars in clarksville and we'd go drinking
here's how he was he would drink
1 2 3 4 5 10 15 20. i mean he's drinking
right when he comes out if he didn't
meet a girl guess what he's doing
getting in a fist fight oh first of all
that's automatically because he was a
linebacker this guy almost made it to
the next level if he didn't meet a girl
no joke his head is going into a car's
window
i mean do we have to like not tonight
bam he would to entertain you guys was
that part of it
frustration it was almost like the movie
remember the program remember the movie
the program cars well that one guy would
go in you know with his psychopath he
would paint his face with the blonde but
you know honestly crazy of a guy as he
was everybody loved them yeah that's
crazy
you tell these stories and people are
like but pat that's not normal yeah you
listen you buy your normal this is our
normal it is the reason i'm so freaking
fascinated by this because i played
college football
tom zenner also played college football
there's a level of camaraderie and
manliness and like you know like but i
feel like in the military it's even more
enhanced like
the camaraderie in football is cool we
get along we'll be battling you know
punchy jump in the face and all that but
military it's life or death it's not
it's not life or death meaning you're
throwing a bomb yeah sure that's damn
sure it is very similar and i i think i
get along with a lot of pro athletes
like i have a lot of um like ufc
fighters that are my friends just
because the culture is the same it's put
in the hard work you know love your love
your can and then
have some fun it's pretty pretty simple
remember one you're doing for a team
when you're doing for a country right no
i'm not saying and one is life and death
right yeah every day yeah
so but but i mean i'm sure it's very
close to to no i'm i'm saying it's
probably not very close that's the
closest thing i can to explain you know
when you're talking to athletes and i
see them see old friends that they used
to play like that one time you brought a
friend we went to yard house who was the
guy that was a basketball player oh
tyrone and he was saying charles what do
you say the waitress came up and said
charles barkley's the greatest player of
all time yeah i'm like what are you
talking about she says michael jordan's
not even in top ten do you remember that
yeah exactly very weird that's what i
remember about your friend yeah
the waitress is what i remember yeah but
you went and used to play basketball
that guy was all county 10th 11th grade
12th guy he was amazing and just you
guys exchanging stories yeah
again to tom's point that we were never
life or but football of any sport i'd
say is the closest well let me just let
me go so so then then matt let me do it
for him i don't think he wants to do it
i'm going to do it on behalf of adam
adam's asking if you can make any
contacts where the military can make an
exception where a 41 year old man
can join the military at least a couple
weeks of basic training i do want to go
shooting though i've never shot a gun
how about that is that crazy what yeah
did you see his mind just got a gun
never shot a gun dude i shot my first i
think i shot when i was four yeah
but this is what i'm saying never shot a
gun exactly
like i live in miami i live in have you
ever shot a gun
very minimal times i'm shocked
50 something years old he's 10 years old
and i'm here for verbal warfare
20 millimeter i own an anti-material
but brother this is the this is the
point of you don't want me and adam
having this is the point of my question
is that like there's a lot of guys out
there we played football it's not like
we're [ __ ] [ __ ] like we've we've
battled on the gridiron but very few
americans have served in the military
and that's like i want to go shoot a gun
just to [ __ ] feel what it's like that
you're sleeping in texas any time you
all are invited adam and i are
bookending two guys that have more
artillery than some countries i think
right then why don't you do this i think
we got a couple guys right afterwards
i'm going to take you through this yeah
let's just go get it done today like pop
your cherry today we you know we don't
have to talk there's a large percentage
of americans who when they see like you
did a video that the gun-free zone video
yeah hilarious bro like robbers come in
guns you bust out your shirt and it says
gun-free zone and they're like oh okay i
guess we'll put down like the way that
you use satire to make fun of these
situations i think is truly admirable
but a large swath of americans really
have never shot a gun they don't get it
they don't get gun culture i'm trying to
let them understand and soak the
knowledge out of you of why it's so
important yeah i mean especially that
one i made from that because it's it's
my way of um combating some of these
ridiculous narratives that i believe for
gun control where you know you're
putting a sign up that says you're an
easy target sounds pretty stupid to me
like school is like what you're saying
just like even at my house if i was like
hey guys no guns in this house no dogs
either just come on in right and then
like here's my instagram so you can see
when i'm out of town like are you that
stupid and like benign in your brain
that you can't understand that there's
evil in the world and the only person
that's gonna protect you is yourself
yeah come on
but by the way you know
the whether you whether you have guns or
not you probably would benefit from
saying you have you put a sign outside
your house that says this house we have
gun shotguns and you say
a freaking rottweiler or a pit bull
lives here attack weather lives here
rather yes
horrible marketing now you may get some
uh some uh some uh what do you call it
some socialist uh flyers of somebody
that's running for office that are gonna
put in front of your building or your
house but you're not gonna have to worry
about somebody breaking into your house
interesting perspective so okay do you
have any other military questions for
him or can we transition this great did
jerry jones have your back during that
controversy did he call you and say hey
man i got this covered because i thought
he alleviated some of that heat with his
power didn't yeah jerry's absolutely
amazing and um i mean from what i heard
he was stoked on the release uh my
business partner evan has direct comms
with him so i'm not that important to
talk to jerry jones i don't think i i
don't rate that high hannah prediction
well the cowboys win a championship
while uh yeah jerry jones is alive still
dude i mean they're back they're
caffeinating them all with black coffee
while jerry jones is alive wow you went
there so you don't think they're gonna
win one i don't i think he needs to step
down and move away
i think he's over what though is gm i
just look they've had their run in the
90s they had to run michael irvin
or just
bring the gm in i just don't see them
winning with him now with him as well
i think it starts with a quarterback but
that's another conversation they've got
a top five quarterback
a long long time it's been 25 26 years
that they haven't won it's been a minute
since we're gonna win this season how
about that this season yeah prediction
time black rifle anybody gamble here
i'll bet five bucks on it let's let's go
you gotta bet can you shake
the season let's shake it off
there we go five bucks adam and matt
have a bet
in the playoffs a first round playoffs
he's saying super bowl five bucks or one
third of a candy or tank of gas or like
[Laughter]
i'll come collecting two bro he is a
collector okay okay sounds good you guys
mind if we get into some stores now
we've learned a lot let's hit some
stories here
uh so one of the ones i want to hit up
is uh how the white house is handling
inflation if you guys are okay with that
let's go into that once uh page uh
page six okay so here we go
the white house wants to redefine
recession ahead of possibility of
disastrous
gdp report economic commentators
frequently used two consecutive quarters
of negative gdp growth
as rule of thumb that an economy is in
recession while the economy shrank by
one point four percent the first quarter
president biden's economic team argued
that even if second quarter gdp is
uh negative it's still unlikely that
would indicate the economy isn't a
recession the national bureau of
economic research defines a recession as
a significant decline in economic
activity that is spread across the
economy
and lasts more than a few months and
looks
at everything from inflation-adjusted
income various employment statistics
consumption expenditures and industrial
production google however defines the
phenomenon as a purely temporary
economic defined decline during which
trade and industrial activity are
reduced generally identified by a fault
in gdp in two consecutive quarters can
you do me a favor go to twitter go to
twitter if you can
and go in yeah go to my twitter the last
thing what white house released
on july 21st i think everybody has to
see this go up a little bit it's so
interesting when they do it and how they
do it keep going up keep going up we
should come up on the next one
go a little lower go a little lower go a
little lower
right there click on that one
oh my god it does that every single time
huh give me a second okay so when you
read that tweet you know what the white
house released
that was released
july 21st which is what five days ago i
think today's the 26th
make make it bigger so they can see it
just click on the no just click on yeah
click on that
zoom out a little bit okay watch that
so uh what is a recession while some
maintain that two consecutive quarters
of fallen real gdp constitute a
recession that is neither the official
definition nor the way economists
evaluate
the state of the business cycle instead
both official
determinations of recessions and
economists assessment of economic
activity are based on holistic
look at the data including the labor
market consumer and business spending
industry production incomes based on
these data it is unlikely that the in
gdp in the first quarter of this year
even this is the key word here this is
the key word this is
this is protecting to say they're about
to announce that there was a decline in
the gdp second quarter watch out and
ends up
even if it followed
by an even if followed by another gdp
decline in second quarter indicates a
recession now if this isn't trying to
redefine a recession pre-midterms i
don't know what it is tom what do you
think about that you know it's just i i
think they're testing our limits to just
how stupid yeah you know we we think we
are they are it's it's just not working
anymore in order to sell this you need
other than very creative writers and
they have some i mean i give them credit
for trying this spin
but the realities are out there
everybody's dealing this with this on a
daily basis and there's no credibility
coming back from the white house anymore
like you would believe them if they said
that we all know the situation right now
um it's just i think they spend so much
time
ignoring the real issues
not finding ways to fix problems that
they start believing it themselves and
every day if there's something new that
they're trying to brainwash us with and
news flash we're just not that stupid
i think collectively people are waking
up yeah for me it's more like a it's a
white house it's like clout over country
where all they care about is the the
feel-good virtue signaling stuff as they
just watch economic collapse happen and
then i mean to your to the point there i
mean they're they're making excuses
already and they're lying well and they
know it's coming they know that report
is going to come just you're like that's
like saying just because this tastes
like water and the second sip tastes
like water
it's not water yeah like
and we're smarter than you you have to
believe us yeah but that's not why
that's not water yeah because we make
all the definitions you don't we're adam
what do we trust them anymore like come
on like over
the pandamik yeah are they coming in
here does anybody believe this that's
the point though that's that i think
that's the main question because
what's the approval rating what approval
rating just came out i i saw something
33 because i know adam always talks
about that as bad as his approval rating
is it's not lower than trump
did it it might be worse now yeah his
approval rate i think is the lowest like
all-time low
beating out trump so if i'm correct
though the trump's approval rating was
like at the end of his term right it was
at the very end where
yeah and then after the january stuff
but this is like this is now you know
not even two years into it adam what do
you think when you hear this kind of uh
you know well i think the narrative the
the gdp uh report is supposed to come
out on thursday i believe and i don't
believe that there's going to be a
pretty picture in sight so right there
now they're trying to do a spin job they
have uh what's a new press secretary
karine st pierre she's out there sort of
doing like mental wrestling trying to
redefine what a recession is but
whether they come out and say it's a
recession or not i think americans feel
what's going on right with inflation
with surging home prices people feel it
so
uh they're gonna look whether it's
republican or democrat nobody wants to
own that you have yeah we have it you
know congratulations you're going to try
to do a spin job but at the end of the
day the voters are going to have
you know their opportunity to say what's
on their mind this november in the
midterms and we'll see what happens but
clearly economically it's not a pretty
site in america right now we talked
about the fed doing the
quantitative tightening right now so
they're saying that inflation is what it
reached 9.1 in june they're starting to
say that it's coming down they're
starting to say that gas prices are
coming down and whether you're a
democrat or republican i think we are on
the same page we want prices to go down
we want inflation to go down we don't
want a shitty economy so
we'll see what kind of spin job they do
but
uh for the sake of the country i'd like
to see us not in a recession but like
you talked about on your housing uh real
estate housing
um segment you did recently i think the
what
my fear is it is the worst still
upon us like if this is the worst of the
worst right now i think americans have
dealt with it is the worst is something
worse coming i think that's the question
right now so i'm going to read this from
an economist if you can pull this one up
because this is all over the place
uh here's an economist his name is uh
nouriel roubini just so you know who
nouriel robini is he's an iranian
american economist he teaches at nyu
stern school of business and chairman of
roubini macro associates so this is not
a
regular guy he got his the degree from
harvard
and uh he's done very well for himself
he also went to hebrew university of
jerusalem i know you would appreciate
that so so economists uh shallow
recession uh calls are totally
delusional roubini warrens this is a
bloomberg article
he said the us is facing a deep
recession as interest rates rise and the
economy is burdened by high debt
loads calling those expecting a shallow
downturn delusional there are many
reasons why we are going to have a
severe
recession and a severe debt and
financial crisis the chairman and chief
executive of macro associates said on
bloomberg tv on monday the idea that
this is going to be short and shallow is
totally delusional look
you got two sides you pick and choose
who you want to believe okay i was in
l.a this last week and i was given the
talk
and i decided to open up my message in a
completely different way
on wednesday night we had a dinner with
one of our uh lawyers uh entertainment
lawyer solid guy we went to crustaceans
great conversation
anytime i go to dinner with a lawyer i
have a time clock where i said at 45
minutes i'm gonna say i got an emergency
call we gotta go it's been great seeing
you but this is
some money that way two and a half hours
later we're having a blast funny guy and
he's a badass
and uh so we're sitting we're having
said pat you won't believe it you know i
just uh my house in toluca lake two
thousand square feet three bedrooms
right in outside of van nuys like to
luca lake chandler he says 1.8 million
dollars he says i can't even believe it
he says how can you live in a one point
who can't afford a 1.8 million dollar
house three bedrooms so i go and i'm
giving this speech at santa monica
i went to santa monica and i spoke at
montebello and at granada hills so
here's how i opened it up i said i got a
question for you guys i said raise your
hand
if you have no plans of leaving
california in the next three to five
years okay everybody's looking at me
like what as let me ask this question
one more time
raise your hand if you have no plans of
leaving the states you love in the next
three to five years
seventy percent of hands go up that's
seventy percent is to me it's low i
thought it was going to be higher they
have no plan no plans of leaving in the
next three to five years and how many
people in the room by the way four
hundred people okay
300 people are not leaving dude so 300
people are not leaving so i said raise
your hand and for the first time in your
life you're actually considering leaving
the state of california thirty percent
leave the room i'm like okay interesting
it's a hundred people though that's a
lot of people so i set the phone i said
can i just speak to the people that are
planning on staying here yes absolutely
i said if you're staying in california
what you're telling the world
is you like being part of the state that
has the highest gas prices okay you're
okay with that you're saying you're okay
with being in the state that has the
highest state taxes period you're okay
with that you're saying you don't mind
being in a state with the highest all-in
taxes you're okay with that you're
saying you don't mind being in a state
that has the highest homelessness in
america you're okay with that i said do
you want me to continue you don't mind
having the most by the way this friday
they're announcing masks are coming back
in l.a just so you know i said you don't
mind stop this is this is in l.a you can
see that you don't mind the fact that
you're overly regulated controlled
everyone's telling you everything you
need to be doing you're okay with that
right i said do you still planning on
staying here their hands weren't yup
we're still planning on staying i said
no problem then if you're planning on
staying here why don't we do a little
bit of math together let's just show
let's do it i said a friend of mine had
a dinner with two nights ago
he said he just sold his 2 000 square
foot house barely 2 000 square feet
three bedroom two bathroom for 1.8
million dollars i said do we have a
realtor here lady stands up i said can
you help me do math here together yes if
i'm buying a 1.8 million dollar house
that's only 2 000 square feet barely in
his three bedroom if i got a family of
four i can barely live in this place
how much of a down payment do i need to
put on this 1.8 million dollar house she
says 10 minimum i said what's 10 of 1.8
million 180. how many middle americans
in california have 180 000 not a lot but
let's just say you got it so you put 180
000 down that 1.8 now you're financing
what 1.62 i said can you tell me what's
a mortgage payment on 1.62 she says
roughly 12 thousand dollars pni
everything includes that's a perfect
fine i said this twelve thousand dollars
i make is it pre-tax money or after tax
money she says that's after tax money so
what do i need to make pre-tax
you need to she says around twenty
thousand dollars to afford twelve
thousand dollars i said perfect i said
is everyone tracking they're like we're
tracking that's a perfect
what is the number typically
you're only supposed to spend per month
on your mortgage payment isn't it
supposed to be a third yeah it's
supposed to be a third
so for a 2 000 square foot house that's
only three bedroom if you need to make
20 grand pre-tax money what do you need
to make to be able to afford a third of
a go into a mortgage payment they said
sixty thousand dollars i said what's
that times twelve seven twenty i said
how many guys are gonna make 720 in
california the next thirty to five years
i said now let me ask you this how many
are still planning on staying in the
state of california you should see what
happened i said how many of you just
based on it that are open to the idea of
leaving the state in the next three to
five years you know what happened what
happened of the 70 half of them raised
their hands and they said that's just
not sustainable huh i said then let me
speak to the other guys that are
planning on staying here how the hell
are you going to get to 7 20. tell me
i'm curious yeah i'm curious i really
want to the numbers just don't make
sense i mean what do you think boy
you know the media
the gap is ridiculous and on top of that
add all of this inflation add all of
this stuff that's going on
how are you going to be ready for this i
don't understand how people in
california survive well i mean why are
you guys looking at me um by the way the
weather's great yeah yeah and the rams
just won the super bowl even on top of
that too it just the the pressure that
the the federal government did with the
lockdowns and state specifically in
california i mean they just ruined the
middle class and then the inflation
right after i mean
it's the whole like who who gets the
judge in essential business you know and
then you look at states like this great
state of florida and desantis who i hope
is president one day and um texas like
they incentivize small businesses and
you know and that's what we should be
doing rather than letting these you know
conglomerate huge corporations just
swallow up the the small man like it
sucks hey pat to your point about mass
coming back in l.a so about i'd say
about a week and a half ago i started
getting the alerts from the la times on
my phone in a week the numbers are up
where there's probably i couldn't
believe it i was so depressed i mean
literally i could not believe what i was
reading and they kept throwing it at you
for the next three or four days
a couple days ago the l.a times sent out
a a little alert that said that the
levels have tapered down a little bit so
i i i bet there's some powerful forces
in la that are saying there is no damn
way you're doing that again because i
don't know man i'd be shocked if they do
it again it was trending that way but i
just saw one that said that the numbers
have gone down a little so you know la
is on a tipping point right now because
we have a mayor election coming up this
fall correct and there is a progressive
on one side and there's rick caruso on
the other side who i believe personally
will fix la i mean he's got a background
of doing that he's very tough he ran as
a democrat even though he's he's a
businessman he saved usc i mean if you
want a fascinating read look up in the
la times the story about how rick caruso
was brought in as the de facto ceo of
usc after they were facing billions of
dollars in settlements from a rogue
doctor abusing patients and whatnot i
mean they couldn't have been lower he
brought in the new football coach
essentially lincoln riley he got them
back from being out in in debt from
these huge payments he saved usc this
guy's smart he'll fix homelessness he'll
bring hope to people i think he'll help
with business i mean it is a big big
thing coming up in november in
california with that mayoral election in
l.a on friday night we had dinner with a
couple guys that are you know hollywood
type of guys you know actors producers
directors and we're having dinner with
them and i said so you guys politically
you you don't lean towards the right you
you lean towards the left this is what
side you've been on yeah what about it
how do you feel about what's going on in
your city and your state what do you
think about masks next week what do you
think about your governor
and and you'd be amazed what they said
they said pat low key
there aren't many people in hollywood
that support this guy but what's the
alternative if you're going to be vocal
about it you have to if you're in the
entertainment industry you have to even
in the entertainment business you either
support just to get career advancement
or you just don't talk about it okay
they're not happy about the math can you
pull up that nbc story i just sent you
look at this l.a county indoor mask man
they could come back this week look at
the date yesterday july 25th there you
go l.a county indoor
mass management it's going to come back
this week i think you nailed it on the
head though because cancel culture isn't
just like a media internet thing it is
in professional like los angeles a lot
of my friends who are actors will on the
side like whisper in my ear i have a
clock at the house and i you know but if
they were to say that to anybody on set
they're fired um in a hurry
that's that that's just how it starts
right oh i heard he's a gun owner and
then it's like well he he looked at me
weird he he sexually saw and then it's
it's the cancel the cancel play you know
they do it to so many people hey to
matt's point here so you guys heard
about chappelle's show that got canceled
in minneapolis last week at first avenue
all right he's performing that's
prince's club remember first avenue
purple rain
epic club in downtown minneapolis all
set to perform they cancel on him on
wednesday so then a different theater
booked him and he went over there and
did some killer shows but they talked to
the people like why would you do this
and they said it was about the trans
right the trans topic
and the the owners of
first avenue we're saying hey we had to
do it our lives were being threatened
our families lives were by threatened
by
trans supporters the ones that came out
there and protested and were throwing
eggs at people waiting in line so
to everybody's point here just because
they're acting some way publicly doesn't
mean that's how they really feel but
people's hands are tied they're backed
into a corner and a lot of people let me
tell you what i did so uh uh while i was
there this is this is what i think a lot
of people need to be doing okay
and and if you're listening to this if
you don't like your state well do
something about it so pat what can i do
about it very simple let me simplify it
for you number one if you know people
that would make great governors
go challenge them to run
and back them up if you think somebody
is a person that would be a good leader
go have a serious conversation with them
one of the days while we're in la
i go to a very uh
very very well-known a man named dudley
and i sat down with him for 45 i said so
tell me how's california been last
obviously i'm first trying to recruit
him to florida it's the first thing i do
then if you say no to moving to florida
or texas and then i say you're planning
on staying here yes perfect you don't
want to stay here yes you love your
state yes you want to do something about
it yes
why don't you run
why do i need to run
who else needs to run
if none of the great leaders who have
backbone want to run then who the hell
is going to write is it always going to
be somebody somebody else that's going
to run if you love your state you love
the policies well my way of contributing
is in a different way totally get it i
mean we all have a different way of
contributing but eventually
if you really want to change policies
you got to run
yeah but it's not pretty of course it's
not pretty
it's not supposed to be attractive it's
not supposed but go run it is the only
way
if the people in california truly want
their state to improve
get behind a candidate and rally
rally and be a flag carrier like never
before do whatever you can for that
person to get elected and then
help make some changes
it is worth it or if that's not what you
want to do you can't sit on the
sidelines so well you know maybe one day
and maybe one day and maybe one day yeah
maybe one day and maybe one day no then
you have the choice that you got to make
for your family so one guy said well pat
you know
i'm not gonna leave i'm gonna stay here
okay so let me ask you a question what's
your point you sound brave when you say
the way you say it like like others who
leave are less brave than you i said let
me ask you a question didn't your
parents leave another country to come to
america are your parents not brave
if they left mexico to come here were
your parents not brave if my family left
iran to come here are they should they
have stuck it out in iran
you know either
impact through policies
or make the better choice and move but
the pain must be felt and you know what
i i think if they don't have the
wherewithal or the ability to run for
governor and they're powerful and
important and they could have influence
somebody has to stand up and support a
candidate that goes against the grain
that you're going to take some public
backlash from it i think that would
almost be as brave as running for don't
you if some powerful person in hollywood
supported a rick i mean it does happen a
little bit but you get the jeffrey
katzenbergs of the world who are just
attacking caruso and whatnot but even if
you couldn't run for governor i think if
you supported somebody that was
pro-business or wanted to actually clean
up a state i mean that's bravery too
have we invited caruso yet or no i don't
know if we have we can can you text rob
and say let's invite him i mean i know
it's florida but we'd get him a few
million eyeballs i'd love to speak with
hey can i ask you guys a question just
back on the recession thing i'm curious
about this because i have a theory so
regarding the recession how cognitive do
you think joe biden is literally do you
think he's driving anything do you think
he has any original ideas whatsoever
because here's my thought
there's no way in hell he's on the
ticket in 2024 and he knows it so i
think if he's cognitive enough that he's
thinking about legacy right now he spent
his whole life in government
and i think it's it's his motivation is
to not be the worst president so he's
making day-to-day survival decisions not
leadership decisions because he's
trending to be as bad as jimmy carter i
mean that's who you compare him to right
now so my question is do you think he
has is he calling the shots on any of
this or is he just back hopefully
reading the prompt or not screwing that
up
i mean that's i think that he's waking
up in the morning to a b12 shot and his
handlers and their whole goal is for him
not to say something stupid i don't
think anything's coming out of him i
think it's his corrupt team that's
pushing this progressive narrative i
mean all the all the dad is there like
when he has a cue card telling him where
to sit at your chair and you have to
capitalize your i mean at this point
you're not even coherent and i was
making fun of it there for a while but
to me as like a an american and i love
this country like my family it is my
family it's given me everything it's
terrifying it's absolutely [ __ ]
terrifying and then when everybody goes
hey well you need to step down i'm like
so you want kamala harris in there
like
it's just it's bad form right now and
bro i don't even think democrats want
him to step down because they're afraid
kamala to run it because it's even going
to be worse no notice how much they hide
kamala from the camera yeah so it's not
like i know you can't find her anywhere
these days no but by the way you know
what i knew a lot of good friends in
high school and in in middle school and
junior high school
and this this is pure shout out to
kamala harris i had a lot of good
friends that were great at hide and go
seek she's the champion i mean i've
never met anybody that's good as she is
at it do do you think um like
what's your opinion on on biden right
now because
i mean
where does it go so for me i've said
this many times i think in life
in companies the sooner you realize
whether you are a number one
a number two a number three a number
four or a number five six seven eight
nine ten the better you're going to do
if you plug in an eight to be the one
that company is going to collapse
if you put a one in a seven you're under
utilizing the one and eventually that
seven's gonna leave and be a one
elsewhere okay
but a one is a one
and a five is a five and you just have
to understand that it took carmilla
years to realize that you want to win a
championship you're not going to win as
a one ai didn't win as a one okay
westbrook so
you have to know and by the way
this is by far one of the hardest thing
to
embrace
it's the hardest thing to embrace to
know that you're not a1 okay
so biden to me
i think bernie sanders is moral one then
he's the number one i know this sounds
weird but forget about being a socialist
i think sanders is a in the socialist
community he is a one i think in the
democratic policies i don't think he's
the one i think there's plenty of guys
that would be better ones than he would
be so i don't see the guy as a leader i
see him as a potential number two number
three i think two is even high i think
he's a number three four five five guy
do you think the administration has a
responsibility to tell the american
public the the
his health
or you saw the interview with pete did
you see the interview with pete when
pete was being pushed yesterday i don't
know if you guys saw that or not where
are
you
did you see that or no he was being
pushed yesterday
and he says hey uh uh i don't know who
was pushing him but he was asking very
good questions says listen in 2019
uh you
you posed the question that you don't
think
president trump was mentally fit to run
america
and
president trump wasn't stumbling and
then he shows all these pictures by the
way you have to see this interview you
know we'll find it and we'll post it and
he says president trump wasn't stumbling
president trump wasn't shaking hands
with ghosts president trump wasn't being
told where to sit president trump wasn't
doing any of that stuff how come you're
not publicly
calling out the mental fitness of
joe biden as you did of trump and it's
ten times worse and obviously pete
buddhich says i i can see
the level of insult in your question so
i will dismiss that he says no no you
can't do that you you said
president trump three years ago wasn't
mentally fit to run the country
and he never went through what this
guy's going through he says well i'd
love to see president trump ride a
bicycle that's what he said about the
fact that yeah
there was a doctor that came out and
said the same thing a doctor that
treated trump and biden
and he said what was the same thing i
think it was the exact same question
but that's that's how they respond right
you put a cat in a bathtub and they just
react with violence or anger um and then
no logic you know just answer the
question you see this everywhere you see
shapiro put guys in that position you
see all these all these and they just
can't respond they they
get mad and say well that's offensive
and walk out of the interview like
that's not debate that's just you being
a child here's my question you're lost
if biden is better as a number two which
i actually fully agree with i don't
think he's well i think he's side
dealing i think he's i think he's the
accidental president the timing you know
kovid trump you know
exactly his polling wasn't obviously
doing so great biden he was more the
conservative democrat not the leftist uh
bernie sanders but
would you have a problem if in fact
obama was helping him call the shots
behind the scenes or even a susan rice i
think that gives me a lot more comfort
if someone quote unquote grown up in the
room was actually helping run the
government rather than biden meaning
he's not exactly who you want in charge
or do you want him in charge because he
is the president i i don't have a
problem if quote unquote his handlers i
don't think it's like the daycare staff
i think it's susan rice i think it's um
secretary of state i think it's tony
blinken i think there's some people
around him who i do
trust enough to control the government
so do you have a problem if it's obama
actually calling the shots let me ask
you a question
uh do you think if you're in my ear you
can help me be a better basketball
player
yeah i can you think you can do that i
can shoot show you form you can show me
form just like if i can you if can he
probably help me be a better but shooter
but no matter how much you're in my ear
can you help me play in the nba no sir
why not
some things you just can't teach what if
what if jordan's in my ear
let's say jordan every day spends two
hours in my ear telling me how to be a
better basketball player am i going in
the nba probably not the nba but your
mentality you'll probably get a lot of
shows everybody
has limitations in different areas of
life
president biden's limitation at best is
a vp of opera vp of ops not a president
i'm with you even the point i'm trying
to make to you is i can go and talk to a
vp of ops to be the ceo of an insurance
company
and no matter what i tell that vp of ops
in his ear he's not going to be able to
execute
there's a lot of experiences you need
you need to be a leader
and biden just doesn't have it today
maybe 30 years ago i don't know maybe it
would have been different if his mental
fitness was different but he doesn't
have the capacity today to be look i'm
on the same page i don't think he's a a
qualified number one i you know i will
say that it's i haven't seen anything
that's like all right he has full-blown
dementia he has no clue what he's
talking about i think obviously satire
and humor and you know doubling down on
anything that he does wrong he fell off
the bike i get it but
is it that bad i guess that's my
question how bad is it really i think
it's
as almost as bad as it can get
he can't talk i mean you have to sit
down and listen to an interview i mean
did you not watch him go end of quote
repeat the line like sit there and read
that he wronged burger king he read that
yeah even in saudi arabia
and that's the thing it's not like for
me it's like you had a bad day it's
consistency is king and it's
consistently awful and it's
progressively getting worse i mean even
look back when he was vp or look back a
year ago like you're seeing a massive
decline like
all politics aside being the president
of the united states is a really really
hard job right the weight of the world
everybody's going to scrutinize you on
the left or the right your travel
schedule it is the hardest job in
america right so
when you put someone with the mental
decline that he has in one of the
world's most challenging jobs yeah and
here's the thing he's vulnerable so the
progressives are all over him i mean
he's just a little sucker right now
falling for all of that if he was a ceo
the board of directors would be removing
them right about now don't you think
thank you that's a perfect way of
putting it but by the way let me let me
ask you this do you think he makes it
out
do you think he matches it's a long time
two and a half years that's a long time
i don't think so no you don't think he
makes it out you don't you also don't
think he's gonna make it up uh in the
primaries he said i'll come down
something along the lines of i'll come
down with a disease and i'll be switched
out i think that's exactly what yeah
but you know what i think the the
democrats are so afraid of kamala haras
having that you know just being in front
of the microphone every single day that
they'll prop him up any way they
possibly can like weekend at bernie's if
they have i actually agree with you this
is what's crazy the way
this is what's crazy
for for somebody that's you know
follows like history first person to
first person to do this and all that
stuff
i i don't know
i i don't know if
history
wants to have kamala as the first women
president i'd much rather have hillary
as the first in heaven i know that
sounds very weird to say that but
it's very weird like you have a choice
between kamala and hillary to be the
first ever
unbelievable
she dropped out of this
listen
the answer is neither yeah the answer
isn't like i'm i'm not sitting here
campaigning saying i'm gonna
volunteer to go help hillary but there's
no way
at least at least hillary
you know
hillary was you know
a person that could get up and
articulate a message you know she's bs
in you you know she's just saying
whatever it's going to take at that time
but have you heard kamala given some
answers and she's always laughing and
she's got that weird vibe of the way she
speaks that
i actually don't even think it's close i
think hillary is way more qualified than
a kamala okay whether you like hillary
or not robotic you know paid whatever
she's killing people whatever you want
to say about hillary fifty percent of
america voted for her to be president
she went to yeah and she and she lost
by a slim margin to donald trump
kamala didn't even get one percentage of
the democratic primary vote it's not
even and called the president
but here let me let me toss on my tin
hat for a second because that very
statement i think justifies an exit of
biden at some point durham is during his
term because the progressives will have
the opportunity in kamala with her
influence will have the opportunity to
go the first ever female
african-american president did not earn
given right participation trophies are
real in america
that's what it seems like for me will
happen even if it's six months out or
something i don't know but yeah but it's
not earned
let me let me let me give you a dark
dark perspective that i have in this
topic
uh how much influence you think hillary
has today in america a lot okay i i do i
think a lot
oh bro bro let me tell you my assessment
but again i'm fully i'm a business guy
i'm an entrepreneur i'm not a guy that's
involved in this world but i will tell
you this
i think
she has a lot of influence and i think
the reason why biden may not step down
if there is even is any influence left
is because of hillary that hillary
will not
she cannot accept
kamala being the first president
i don't think i think if hillary has any
influence
she's probably the one that wakes up
every morning telling biden's assistant
to give him vitamin c to give the
vitamin b12 yeah to give him trt to give
him whatever it is that he's on to just
make it for two and a half more years
because hillary over her dead body to
have kamala be a president before her
anybody
but kamala she would be okay for
michelle to be the first president she
would not be okay with come out being
the first president so i think i think
in a way
hillary's keeping biting in office for
another two and a half by the way i
don't think your assessment is fully
wrong at all
if you're talking about someone like
hillary and you're seeing that if
comment just gets kind of caked walked
into the presidency hillary's like this
does not sit well with me at all but
it's how much money i spend on my
celebration party you know i didn't go
down i really think that part of biden's
main if he can have these thoughts is
not letting hunter blow him up
just keeping that thing so that thing
doesn't explode
uh truly because that could just open up
pandora's boxes so much and you know
he's never that's why governors make
good presidents because they've run
something a state they've made big
decisions when you're a senator for 40
years what have you done you run for
office every once in a while you take
handouts you know you vote but you're
not a leader you know you don't do that
kind of thing so i think
this whole hunter you know it's so funny
because if i have an extra muffin at
starbucks shonda knows and i get in
trouble i can't get away with anything
bite and get away with all you get in
trouble for having a muffin are you
yelling have you ever not been being a
black guy have you not met her yeah
yeah i mean uh dude i love trump jr
great great dude and i'm like i can't
imagine under um trump's presidency if
he did one like one ounce of like the
the ton that by or hunter has done like
do we they just completely ignore it now
like as if it's totally fine to be
smoking crack and having sex with
prostitutes and all these other things i
mean do you buddy it looks like you're
having a lot of fun but you know not as
the
president i don't know if it's ignored
it's like an embarrassment man yeah i
agree with you i don't there's nothing
there's nothing attractive about the
president's son smoking crack with
hookers no doubt the question is did he
sell his country out or not and that's
remains to be seen so the jury's still
out real quick i want to adam you said
earlier you would feel more comfortable
if you thought that obama was running
behind the scenes right
but that's what's happening it's it's
all obama holdovers anthony blinken was
a former deputy deputy secretary of
state to obama ron clain was uh chief of
staff to al gore he was a part of the
obama like these are all obama's
holdovers and this is exactly what they
want biden wasn't an accidental
president he's exactly who they wanted
they didn't want bernie they ran bernie
out twice because he was closer to trump
than he was to the democratic party in a
lot of ways he was a populist he was
weirdly america first he was closed the
borders like so this is exactly what
they want so i wonder
how we'd be better off
if that was the case if it was obama
people again it just is this is exactly
what they want
was there a question there yeah like
like you said so i'm asking you got to
you're like are you going to take that
on camera everybody's watching like what
are you going to say tomorrow sometimes
yeah okay there it is
well that's the question you you said i
would feel better if i thought obama's
people were running the show no i said
obama okay so it's it is obama it's
obama it's obama's people it's obama's
secretary of state it's all excuse me
his chief of staff it's al gore's chief
of staff it's all these people they are
running the show and this is what we're
getting so how do you feel better about
that because it's not joe biden well
it's it do you want biden run in the
country or not that's you can't say oh
he's not fit to run the country but i
also want him to be leading the country
which one is it i i'm saying that i feel
comfortable with obama running the
country if it is if he is calling up
obama being like barack a little over my
head right now what's your advice i'm
[ __ ] okay with that because i think
barack obama at least can control
things that biden can't so you can't
have your cake and eat it too do you
want bite and run in the country or not
well i don't think he is to be fair i
don't think he is at all yeah i think
what he's trying to say is no and no is
what he's trying to say but let's
transition into a different topic and
let's talk about tanks so the china
deployed tanks against protesters what
we do know
and what we don't this is a newsweek
store if you want to pull this a viral
video of tank
uh processions on chinese street have
caused a global store last week with
claims
across social media alleging that
china's military was drafted into
protected banks following a major
financial scandal posts on twitter which
have received hundreds of thousands of
engagements alleged that the vehicles
were deployed to prevent a run on the
banks after millions of dollars of worth
of deposits were frozen from account
holders earlier this year
rizal the location mentioned in the
videos itself has not been at the center
of the banking protest either the city
is more than half 500 kilometers from
henan when where demonstrators have been
widely reported the general public
featured in the video certainly does not
appear to be energized for protest
most passers bayer are glancing uh idly
at the military vehicle so what so okay
so let's say that's what it is newsweek
let's say that's what it is
i mean is this a show
is this like a fourth of july show
celebration hey let me go see some tanks
i mean how often do tanks just come out
why did the tanks come out are they
going shopping are they going to in and
out to order a double cheeseburger i
don't know what are these guys doing are
they just kind of playing video games
and hey let's go show off and hell let's
get some girls and stuff why are tanks
parked outside of a band i'm not
speculating i think that's a safe
question to ask i'll just i think it's
intimidation i don't think the chinese
play around with their tanks you're used
to seeing those when they're out in
tiananmen square doing some damage um
yeah i don't i don't think anything's
accidental there even though i feel so
bad for these chinese citizens man yeah
the ones well first of all they lock
them down if someone has a sniffle right
they knock down a whole city and then
with these funds now this happened you
know a long way away from where that was
but
man you know you think about china you
know you think how they are under the
thumb chinese citizens and you wonder
man could they ever rise up guns are
basically illegal in china i don't think
chinese citizens could ever do anything
even if they wanted to this is
intimidating seeing this yes i think
that's like a general military tactic
right there just show force it's letting
you know what we can do it's the same
thing when you're on target and uh
people are getting squirrely and you fly
a f-16 right over their heads and you're
like just so you know we're here you
know
say something we're here yeah yeah by
the way they were saying billionaires
were trying to take out 58 billion out
of china and china's like now you made
your money here you ain't taking it out
of here there's a lot of people that
want to leave china but they can't be
taking their money out
uh with china so and do you have the
story about what happened with mortgages
in china and the banking system did you
did you did you see that story or no is
this the one
no this is this is around the high net
worth individuals uh there you go around
10 000 high net worth individuals in
china are seeking to leave their country
this year and could be okay it's 48
billion in wealth with them according to
a new wealth migration report by hellion
partners and investment migration
consultancy interesting
hong kong members rank high yeah there
was a story about what's going on with
mortgages in china
they're in uh they're in some
interesting uh
a situation right now by the way i think
they just bought like 300 acres in south
dakota and desantis is not having it the
santa's like sitting saying hey what are
you doing buying all the farmland in
america he said he's causing a huge
problem let me tell you that concerns me
way more than what's happening when this
china banking situation we covered the
story a couple years ago with this ever
grand i never even heard of them prior
to this but
you know they've over leveraged and
they've built up crazy amounts of
construction and a lot of chinese
citizens have bought pre-construction
and and you know crazy debt and there's
all this stuff going on in china
i don't really give two shits about
chinese real estate i care about
american real estate okay i care about
if china is buying up u.s farmland and
desantis is calling out
now you're talking to me okay because i
doubt many americans are waking up most
americans are waking up trying to pay
their own [ __ ] rent and their own
mortgage i got to be worried about
what's going on in china now let me tell
you why don't give two [ __ ] i get it for
the macro economy no no but most
americans are more focused on their real
estate yeah so when desantis calls out
what's going on in china like we talked
about
um schools texas a m for example takes
money from confucius institutes so they
can teach chinese doctrine uh
indoctrination to students and take
their money harvard's on this like that
to me is way more of an issue when china
is taking their money and their soft
power and bringing it to the united
states whatever happens to china i get
it there's a real estate situation going
on
figure it out the only reason you you do
see what's going on with china is the
same way
when you're buying a house you do comps
to see how much houses around your
community are selling for and if you're
a rifle a coffee company you want to
know what your company is worth and you
go to someone that's doing valuation
they're going to do comps to see what
other coffee companies your size are
selling for with the ebitda revenue
market states countries where you're at
it's the same we have to see what's
going on in china's real estate market
and loans because that's a case study to
see what could potentially happen to the
american economy that's the only reason
we would look at what's going on over
there because uh it's a scary side
they're having a they're having a rough
situation over there china's home buyers
are running out of patience with the
real estate slump last week the spike in
reported numbers of home buyers halting
mortgage payments prompted many banks to
announce their low exposure to such
loans across
banks covered by goldman sachs average
exposure to property including mortgages
was just 17 if more home buyers refuse
to pay their mortgages the poor
sentiment would reduce demand and
theoretically prices in a vicious cycle
so these these are the reasons why you
do pay attention to some of this stuff
but going back to your point
you're right why are these guys buying
up all this land okay why by the way one
of the places they bought they bought
300 acres of land in north dakota 20
minutes from a military base
what are you doing
like you have to ask a motive yeah
yeah why yeah why are you buying it near
a military base 20 minutes away bill
gates buy up a
crapton lounge well he's the biggest
landowner for farmland
by the way i'm way more okay with bill
gates owning land in the united states
than china the ccp i mean what are we
talking about here when you compare this
to the article that just came out about
their interfering with nuclear weapons
and how they were installing listening
devices the question isn't why are they
doing it the question is why are we
allowing it to happen good why is the
government not stepping in and saying no
not a [ __ ] chance we're gonna wait
like this is this is absurd 20 miles
from an air base of course they're going
to install listening devices the
question isn't why it's why is it
happening or excuse me why are we
letting it happen i guess the question
would be what is the law against the
country buying land in another country
what is the law
desantis says he wants to make it a
state law in florida so so meaning if
there isn't a law
of doing that well then you need to
create a law years ago when trump was
uncomfortable with huawei's
daughter that was going around talking
to iran and she was in canada i don't
remember if you remember that whole
scandal and huawei was a number two or
number three phone company in the world
what did he say
he said you can't do huawei and us and
why we took a massive hit huawei was
coming up in america huawei took a
massive hit
if if this is what is going on the
president has the ability to sanction
anyone from china buying agriculture or
land in u.s they could do that they can
add those sanctions on chinese investors
that is simply one announcement for him
to make well you hit the nail on the
head chinese investors they're not
coming out and saying hi i'm here on
behalf of the ccp and i'd like to buy
some farmland it's some guy named
whatever or tic toc or yeah that's a
whole nother conversation with white
dance china has but it could be just a
chinese investor there's nothing illegal
about in a guy who's showing up and
buying some property that but you know
that if a guy shows up with a couple
billion bucks from china it's like
who's really pulling the strings there
right that's the only question
there's nothing illegal about a guy
buying property or corporation buying
property it's just how far removed are
from the ccp well my assumption is not
far china has no problem you know saying
every day who their enemy is it's us
right for some reason we just can't say
that and i admit it so i think we just
we should assume anything they do is to
harm us yeah if they're coming here to
buy five acres of farmland you know hang
out plant 5g whatever they're out to get
us pat we've been talking about china
for a few years now at least you know on
the podcast right now do you think we
haven't realized what china is about to
do like is there still people in the
government is the citizens are the
citizens of the united states still
unaware of what china is doing i feel
like
it's out there right
it's probably it's out there but a lot
of people are like oh get over it kind
of just
get over what you know just turn a blind
eye i think because it's easier to to
not care than it is to care
and you think the fact that we're now
that russia you know typically our
largest adversary is now in the war in
ukraine that's kind of taking the
attention away from what china is really
doing most likely yeah and then trying
the chinese presence in afghanistan
after our absolute failure of pulling
out i mean there's
they're making smarter plays you know
and then you get to look at the taiwan
situation um man why what's the chinese
presence in afghanistan now
there i mean
they have a large ci threat they're like
counter intelligence so i mean i'm sure
them they're directly working with the
al-qaeda i mean that they're going to
own afghanistan i'd say eventually
because they're going to do it more
diplomatically
rather than militarily like the russians
tried and we tried and we failed at
um so they'll pump money into it that's
how they do it yeah but you've served in
afghanistan
at any point did you be like why the
hell are we here
didn't we learn from history that russia
couldn't you know take over afghanistan
we've been here for 20 freaking years
taliban isn't going anywhere there's any
part of you that's like yeah why the
[ __ ] are we even here is there any part
of you that's happy you got the hell out
of there or we got the hell out of there
even though it was a disaster on the way
we left at least we got out yeah i think
like it's just like a relationship you
have to be all in or all out and um
yeah
leaving afghanistan would have been fine
if we would have had a phased-in plan
and stuck to it and we did have that but
then they just pulled out and that's a
whole different conversation but
um no i think that the the reasons
they're early in afghanistan we were
hyper successful in our mission and then
we kind of got lazy and complacent and
we sat around and tried to build bases
and then it just became an occupation
and
we kind of suck at occupations because
it's just that you're slowly bleeding
the us economy and having americans die
for
for really no no specific reason and
campaign to to to win like we fight to
win we don't fight to stay uh so
yeah thank god we have elon musk's sex
life to
get us off these crazy topics these do
you think he did dangerous
kinda
you know the other day i saw a i don't
watch golf but i saw an interview
that was very i'm trying to find this to
show to you to answer your question
where the reporter asks this um
golfer he says hey the the
journey you have been told saudi arabia
is on you know all this other stuff
that's going on how do you feel about
the women oppressed the migrant groups
having the rights violated the lgbtq
individuals criminalized the families of
the 81 men accused you know executed in
march and all he's just going okay with
all this stuff that he's talking about
and the guy responds back and i think
it's graham mcdowell i i wish i could
find exactly what he says
to share it with you i loved his
response he says you know it's so
interesting when it comes down to
politics says listen we're golfers we're
not politicians but he says i'm so
curious why do you guys
target saudi arabia but none of you guys
are saying anything about what's going
on in taiwan and what china's doing to
taiwan why don't you
you see the report is like boom silent
so if you're gonna come after me for
saudi why don't you go
after what's going on with
you know taiwan same thing in the nba
right you get those guys they'll never
talk about it they'll talk about other
social issues but they take 500 million
dollars per year from china right so
it's a double standard all the way so
you're bringing up the china deal
and
you you can always tell who is
uncomfortable to call out china
you better believe there's some kind of
a business dealing going on over there
and you know strategically you got to
give credit to these guys because
they're going and buying up people left
and right in america that are for sale
strategically yeah this doesn't mean you
have to like it this doesn't mean it's
the right thing to do
your people are for sale we're buying
them good luck trying to buy our people
okay
good luck buying our people in china
come on try buying our people see what
happens but your people are for sale
i'll never forget when china tried to
buy you
you remember that i do as funny as it
sounds i'm not even bullshitting right
now they remember where we were at when
the email came in we were in dallas uh
texas and addison office so at least i
remember call that so creatures they
were the creepiest zoom we ever they
offered you i think a quarter million
dollars to speak i have the email till
today and then another quarter million
dollars that you're gonna donate or
something i don't you wanna tell the
story yeah he says look we wanna fly you
out to china because this charity
we're willing to give you six hundred
thousand dollars of which we want you to
present a three hundred thousand dollar
check out of your bank account
to us but you're gonna need three
hundred thousand dollars we're gonna
treat you royally and an email came out
mario and i and a couple of our guys uh
got on the zoom with them
it was a pr firm out of new york with
uh folks in china to give six hundred
thousand dollars and soon i'm like
i just wanted to hear them out to see
like
are people actually saying yes to this
and then what is your outcome
is it later on in case because we're
allowed against you for you to come back
and say well he came to china gave us
three hundred thousand dollars to
charity so he was a supporter and sure
all this other stuff so you know it's
but but you got to realize so if
somebody to somebody of 600 000 a lot of
money to somebody like oh you know i'm
gonna go out there and take a look at
this but man a lot of americans are
being sold to china a lot of americans
are being supposed to come back with a
counter offer after you told them no no
it was a very awkward zoom and the man
was a very there was nothing pleasant
the two publicists were very pleasant
there was nothing pleasant about the guy
it was very uncomfortable who was the
guy do you recall like
we have the name of the email but the
guy was a very disturbing and you can
understand think about that pr agency
you answered your own question do people
really take the money that's what
they're doing an american pr agency
representing china interest trying to
suck in influencers and wealthy people
here in the u.s so they can put them in
their back pocket for when they're
needed listen i mean we we
uh uh criticize prostitutes in america a
lot
and they you know they chose to live a
life for ex changing whatever they're
doing you know sex for money but
there's a the real prostitutes are in
hollywood and and and sports that are
taking bigger checks and they're selling
their souls and their country to any
country that's willing to pay the money
so you know we have to kind of uh if
you're really going to talk about
prostitutes you got to really go to the
point where these guys are getting paid
some real money to sell their country
sell their country other people that
yeah that to me
[Music]
that's that's i mean that's just you
know do you ever see a time where there
are people like that can be potentially
tried for treasonous activity
i don't think that'll happen because
there's ways to
cover through it but but but just just
think about it from this standpoint
to be bad for the rest of your life
no matter what the dollar amount is you
bet like look what happened to the devil
look what happened with what's his name
uh who just stepped down from uh uh
who's the guy that just stepped down the
the big wrestling ceo
they forced this guy to step down okay
what did he do behind closed doors he
bought him what's the number now it's
like 14.28 million i don't know what the
number is it's over 14 now how many
people he bought out and how many people
he did that okay so what's the what's
the solution you know what's the
alternative do you know what the real
alternative is hey if you don't come in
i'm going to tell the world about it
here's the reality if anybody ever
threatens you
that they're going to tell you about you
hooked up with them you should tell them
look you're eventually going to tell
them so if you're going to ruin my
marriage now or three years from now
just go running i'm not giving you [ __ ]
yeah because you're going to tell the
world so you know what matter of fact
let's do three-way with my wife go ahead
hey just wanna tell you i screwed up
here's a lady i was looking at a
three-way totally different right okay
and by the way but i know
i'm telling you this i'm
i'm telling you you're a freer man to
take that approach than to take this
approach
every single month you have to be
waiting for somebody to say i want to
bring this out and take it public and
tell you tell this tell them it seems
like kind of a weak way for vince to go
down doesn't it a little bit i mean the
guy was such a hard charger he's the
face of wrestling no one's been more
important in the sport than him yeah but
what's the story he he was having the
board is basically forcing him because
he was
paying women under the table because he
was having sex with relationships
relationships covering things up so was
he paying out of his own money or yeah i
think he was paying his own money so
what's the problem here exactly
well time to go extra marital affairs
it's a bad look it's bad pr i mean well
his wife you know ran for senate in
connecticut i mean she she had a high
profile herself she had a big role in
wwe too so maybe they all just
collectively felt it's time to move on
let's stephanie
i respect that and that's their business
if if they're having the conversations
right now and the wife is saying the
hell is the matter with you
you know i understand all this other
stuff what are you doing and they're
going to have their whatever and they're
going to say you know what this is what
we're doing we're either getting a
divorce or you got to step away yeah
because this is embarrassing the entire
family great make the decision but you
think it was a family decision a wife
decision or the wwe
direction
it is all i'm saying is
if somebody comes and does this to you
they own you for the rest of your life
that's not the way to go out if you're
that guy especially i don't know why no
you need a big tribute by the way can i
tell and this is the truth now this
isn't quite as big as your offer from
china pat
i got an email yesterday with an offer
literally this guy emails me and says
hey i saw your hosting reel on youtube
would you be interested in some
non-sexual naked hosting
so after first of all that's a
compliment here
you should be like you're working out or
something people still want me naked you
know maybe i will have to reconsider
yeah when do you start
what are you starting congratulations
for having a husband where they want to
pay him to be naked what a bold what's
the company
i'll follow up with it today i'll show
you i bet you will sir for the right
price well now that you guys have told
me maybe i will but you know what no i i
don't think i'm that guy the naked part
no they think you are that
you wanna you wanna have i told you the
porn story about what happened when i
was working on chatsworth have i told
this girlfriend okay crazy story so
i'm working on chat's word this guy
comes up to me with another girl
chatsworth was at the time eighty
percent of porn and america was being
produced in chat so i'm that's where i
lived i i went i tell they banned condom
or made condoms mandatory weird little
factoid yeah by the way it all of a
sudden disappeared yeah that's why and
and i used to recruit a lot of these
guys and you would go and you'd all of a
sudden sit down with a bunch of porn
stars and you know recruit for insurance
no i was not in the business but i'm at
chatsworth and this couple comes out and
by the way you can obviously tell
they're in the business very obvious
and uh they look at me and they say so
how much money do you make here i said
i'm the top sales guy i'm the t.o guy
they come to me to close i make very
good money says oh yeah what is that i
make 3 500 a month like oh this is at
valleys
you show me a check for 3 500 bucks i
quit my [ __ ] job tonight
and he says how would you like to make
that a weekend
i'm like damn that's something real good
money 3500 a weekend how old are you by
the way dude i'm 20 i just got out of
the army i'm like my testosterone
level's like 1400 i'm ready to freaking
yeah dude i'm like you know and he says
hey you know for you know if you come
you know here's all you need to do are
you comfortable in front of camera i
said i'm not shy at all i mean i can be
in front so i'm thinking it's like hey
maybe these guys are in hollywood and
they're seeing you know we need a middle
eastern guy to play some kind of a role
and i say yeah are you
comfortable being naked
i said we just took a different turn
here
says well listen let me tell you you
know porn industry chatsworth you're
going to make 3 500 a week you'll have
the time of your life the parties we put
together they're insane all this stuff
i'm sitting i'm looking at this guy and
for like five seconds i'm just looking
at him i'm like okay let's play this
along so okay you go this route what's
life look like 20 years from now
and i came back i'm like yeah no
but i went home and i pulled the biggest
prank on my dad
i go my dad knows this my dad knows it's
till today i said i'm gonna pull it on
him and i'm gonna do i'm gonna keep it
for a week i said dad i got i gotta talk
to you
this is what's that i said dad we're
gonna make some money
we gonna make some money
i said honestly you ain't never gonna
work at this 99 cent store in inglewood
ever again he was a cashier that says
what are we doing i said dad i think
hollywood finally found me
and he said really that's it yep i said
except it's a different kind of
hollywood what do you mean i said i have
to be naked it's going to be porn he
says you're going to do porn i said yeah
he says if you ever do porn you will
never
ever be my son you cannot do porn i said
dad just think about all your friends
watching porn saying that's gabriel's
son
would that not be a proud moment for you
he was so furious so what do i do i
leave him hanging i leave the house nice
do you know for one week this guy
thought i was going to go into this
thing
i didn't believe you at the time huh did
you write a business plan at the time no
did you take your own advice no way
that's a fork in the road though man if
you go down that direction no but but
you're around it every chance you're
you're in l.a you know you're around
every we would have the club we had the
best club for porn stars because we had
the only outdoor swimming pool
so these guys would only one in in
valleys was chatsworth and they would
say hey what time do you guys close
today i'm like 12 o'clock you mind if we
stay two more hours
and it would ask you you're just going
to be out there hanging out if you want
to party with us i'm like listen i'll
give you 30 minutes it's like okay
sounds cool and you know boom people
would show up and then they would leave
but chatswood was the mecca of porn at
the time this is 99 peak pvd well the
valley was always the capital is it no
longer it's no i think when i was living
in north hollywood they they did a
mandatory um condom thing for um porn
actresses and actors and that like
killed all of it i forget i think it
moves states or something um but i'm
just glad at that age 22 no one offered
me that
what would your name be though you would
have a military name right would it be
like jeez sergeant slaughter right there
[Laughter]
you would have been the iranian sheep
yeah come on girls get in line yeah but
i do have a serious question for you but
number one if you know anything about
gabriel bet david he would have disowned
you straight up you were dead to me but
you've said this multiple times that you
have the ability to look deep into the
future you talk about 20 years from now
20 years from now longevity not having
myopic thinking yeah you know these days
like that was pre-internet days right i
mean that was early 2000s i mean the
internet wasn't what it is now social
media now now i mean i can't even tell
you how many girls i run into that do
only fans and like the internet lasts
forever
i don't know how many guys are getting
approached for only fans or porn these
days other than tom i mean i i encourage
you to look into that that sounds like
some good money
but
the ability to think long term and not
for the quick buck how do you grapple
with that what's your advice for young
people out there these days because
there's a lot of easy money out there
especially for women right now it's not
easy i mean i'm not gonna there is no
way of doing it that's like
here's the craziest thing about life
here's the craziest thing about life
we're all being tested the entire time
let me tell you man this is a one big
ass experiment of what you're really all
about and you're gonna fall many times
and you're going to learn a lot about
yourself
and your goal is to keep trying to make
better choices it's not easy so i can't
sit there and play you know hey let me
tell you judge you know i'm not going to
be doing that's your choice and
everyone's in different types of
situations i just will tell you
you know it's it's it's it's very like
even right now yesterday we're talking
about politics i said do you realize the
right candidate
with the right policies that we need in
america today would never get elected
let me say that one more time the right
candidate with the right policies
that america desperately needs today
would never win an election today why
because the right policies would be
folks
guess what
if you vote for me
we're cutting back on 50 of entitlement
programs
we're cutting back on unemployment
checks we're going to go from six months
to 90 days to 30 days
we're cutting back on all this spending
that we're doing we're cutting back on
the military spending that we're doing
we're going to put in more in cyber and
bio warfare and being prepared for that
because right now wars are not going to
be done up there there's going to be
more cyber what russia is doing what
we're going to you're going to have to
get to work the next eight to 12 years
because we all have a job to do
no one would vote for you even though
those are the right policies nobody
would vote for you right okay so
how many presidents become presidents
and they make policies that benefit you
30 years from now nobody nobody does
that everybody becomes a president just
like a the difference between a founder
and a ceo a founder started that company
it's emotional the ceo is just trying to
get the quarterly numbers to be hit so
it looks it's a very different mindset a
lot of today's presidents are just
trying to hit their quarterly numbers
that's all they're thinking about so
going back to your question on what
you're saying uh how you tie these two
together
man life is a test of making short term
decisions versus long term and it ain't
easy problem well i think a lot of it
too
you have to be comfortable with your
decisions and if you're comfortable
doing only fans or whatever or
pornography i think i do it's your body
your choice that's the way i look at it
but what we come back to people when
they uh they take control of your life
and i look back at decisions that i made
that didn't i didn't know what the third
and fourth order effects were going to
be but i got proposed a lot of decent
deals back in the day when i started
youtube it was multi-channel networks
it's when those are really popular they
were taking essentially 12 digital
creators putting them under one
marketing umbrella cross-pollinating
audiences and getting brand deals and
then pushing them through each different
person and i took a look at it and some
of it was like hyper hyper
like i could have made a lot of money
advantageous for me and then some of the
other stuff that i started to see was
all of a sudden the parent company kind
of started to tell these guys what they
can and can't do and i'm an irreverent
guy that likes firearms and i knew that
would always be an implication with
working with these other people and so i
never did it i said screw it you know
what my business partner at the time
jared taylor said hey let's let's start
some shirts and all we did was go i'm
gonna put a design in the shirt that i
want to wear every day and a really
comfy t-shirt that it feels good and we
went with what we wanted how we wanted
to do it and it took longer but the
consequence of those decisions were now
when i'm 35 years old i i own my ideas
and the biggest the worst decision i
ever could have made in business was
allowing someone else to own my
intellectual property because i know
that's what i am i'm a visionary i'm a
really creative guy i'm not the best in
operations but guess you can hire those
people in and all that so it kind of
goes back to when you're talking about
the one through ten analogy
is focusing on your core competencies
i'm like i i'm a creator i'm a visionary
and i wanna own that and i never let
anybody else own me and that's i think
what is a testament to my success i kind
of unknowingly did that but then i
started to realize it more and more as
my life went on
yeah
power and respect to you guys man much
respect to you guys for what you did and
to be where you're at right now you guys
are just getting started i mean right
now uh uh ten thousand veterans that
means if you got ten thousand veterans
working for you got twenty thousand
employees you guys are on track to get
there uh it's a great success story in
america and you guys are not slowing
down do you know to answer your question
for you so for me you know i'm all about
finding ways to drive you or me better
right it's like how do i because when
you run a sales organization with you
know
27 000 insurance agents you have to
learn this person is going to be driven
in a different way than this person then
this person than me than you we're all
different right okay
do you know what is the highest driver
you know who's the highest driver
the highest driver my experience has
been purely pride
pride in what
pride in your last name
okay which is passed down from your
parents
pride in your nationality your heritage
you have to have pride in that that's
your blood you have me whatever people
say you still have to have pride in that
pride in your industry what you do as a
trade you have to have a lot of pride in
your trade whatever i don't care what
you do you got to have pride in your
trade and constantly get better pride in
your community
pride in your family pride in your
country
you can everything is about
representation
this
there's only one of this in the world
okay and that's you
how you represent yourself to the world
eventually one day they're going to sit
there and say
i tell you man i'm just this mad guy man
who's a freaking badass look
you know respect salute this adam guy
the way he lived his life now you know a
lot of times at the beginning but i got
to tell you man this guy's salute
that is worth making the long-term
decisions because all this short-term
stuff that we do
it's going to come it's going to go by
but it's gonna stick around with you for
a very
very long time anybody can take the
short-term victories it ain't hard to do
only a few can take the long-term
victories and i'm telling you right now
history favors those who take the
long-term victories but it's just gonna
take 20 to 40 years for people to
realize who the real players in the game
were not two years not five years not 10
years adam 20 to 40 years that's a v you
know i got a weird call this week from
one from
somebody in the industry
which industry insurance insurance not
not porn no that was retired we know
that's how five seconds it was a thought
and it was gone you're still thinking
about it they're contemplating but this
guy's with my offer and this guy this
guy calls you know what he says he says
uh he says uh hey you know we're part of
the same class now i remember he says uh
so
you know i've done very well himself he
says but you took it to a different
level i said
i i think you killed it yourself as well
you know i call him the 32 year old
brady so you got a 10-year run on you
and uh he says he says to me says uh
everything you said everybody behind
closed doors would say yeah he's not
going to do it yeah he's not going to do
it and for a long time we all believed
it he says but it took 13 years for us
to realize that everything you said you
were going to do
you just you got to be patient
you know market's going to say a lot of
stuff but if you're running for 10 to 20
years you got nothing to worry about you
have a lot to lose sleep over if it's a
three month run you have a lot to lose
sleep over it's a six month run but if
you're running 10 or 20 you're gonna be
fine you know what's interesting about
that because uh i've been asked a lot
over the years about
how to prep for a selection right and
there's mental and physical but the the
foundation of everything that i believe
in when you're going through any
selection especially in the military is
is a 70-day course we'll look at ranger
school 70 days of being uncomfortable
hungry tired mad
guess what you gotta wear a ranger tab
for the rest freaking of your life sick
and i never got why people some people
quit like halfway three-fourths of the
way through ranger school i'm sitting
there going man you're three weeks away
from your life's largest accomplishments
something that you can hang your hat on
something probably down the road when
you have children that when they when
dad shows their little son a ranger tab
the the inspiration that your child will
go man my dad did something hard and
that's what people have to do in this
life and then so often especially with
you know technology and social media all
of our behavioral patterns are becoming
so impulsive immediate gratification and
like put the [ __ ] phone down go feel
the grass like actually dedicate your
life with purpose to something and
follow through with it i mean i do weird
exercises every day like i
i tore my bicep about two years ago and
uh i took a while to rehab almost a year
and i said well i really took for
granted using both arms as silly as that
sounds so i bought a drum set and every
day i paid 20 i play 20 minutes of drums
and at first i could barely do anything
two years down the road you know i feel
like i could play a venue and it's just
weird tasks like that where i challenge
myself mentally and i wish more people
just
wrote it on their little pad it doesn't
have to be crazy like spanish is one of
them but i'm i'm a little lazy on that
one i gotta get better
it goes to show you think about it you
go through
three quarters of ranger school and
people still drop out that just goes to
show how smart the people that set up
the program are because it really does
take that extra effort to make it all
the way through or else everybody would
be trying to do it you know when we were
in dc you know i think one of the things
that this country lacks right now more
than anything especially unfortunately
young people is perspective we went to
the holocaust museum have you guys been
to it in dc yes
unbelievable right i mean how can you go
to the holocaust museum and then have a
complaint about anything in your life
you know i was listening to when jordan
peterson was on with you and he was
talking about new york city and talking
about what a minor miracle it is that
manhattan can exist
with 12 15 million people just the
infrastructure i was thinking the exact
same thing as i was walking the streets
of new york a couple weeks ago how does
this city even happen how does the
garbage get picked up how do the vendors
supply all the food in every single
restaurant and these people never miss a
beat how do the waiters show up how do
the windows get clean you know it's just
unbelievable if we could all take a deep
breath and not be offended by everything
you know we'd understand that what an
amazing existence life is and how lucky
we are everybody wants this vending
machine now and they think life is so
simple you know boom boom boom and you
get what you want but man after walking
out and dash was the one that really
wanted us to go to the holocaust museum
and i'm so glad we said yeah it was at
the end of our trip too
you walk away from that you just need a
couple minutes it's just
unbelievable and they laid it out so
perfectly how they walk you through it
and you get the evolution and you see
how hitler it all started with
brainwashing people it all started with
a plan of four or five years we're gonna
get you thinking a certain way and then
we slide in and do what our plan is and
chilling
perspective is everything and something
i used to say quite often was how do you
have the
the unity and the patriotism of
september 12th without the tragedy of
september 11th
because you look at the effects of what
this country did it it reinvigorated the
american public to believe in itself
believe in the people right screw the
government it's america's awesome
because there's men and women willing to
give everything to protect it in the
name of freedom and liberty it's amazing
but we lose sight on that right because
we're convinced that you know you should
be offended at everything you do it's
just i don't i don't know the answer on
how to
because you have to go and seek
perspective
in these times because stuff is pretty
easy i mean we have inflation but
generally speaking america is a really
rad place to live like the best place to
live and i don't know how we convince
people to have a better perspective to
appreciate that and and move forward
just to like i have one suggestion for
people if you want to have a better
perspective in life and if you want to
relieve from stress from your life you
got to cut out mainstream media if
you're ingesting it all day you've got
to stop doing that it's very harmful i
mean even for someone like me who's in
the news right and i've been in the
media business my whole life when i'm
bombarded with with this stuff you know
the alerts on your phone and whatnot and
then you go and like when adam went to
new york when i went to new york and you
see it's not that bad now unfortunately
you know calif i wish we could have
shown you some good parts and you were
in orange county orange county feels
different too doesn't it like a lot
better night and day different mentality
down there not in there so so tom tell
us about your podcast because we have
when's the last time you were on a
podcast with us by the way i think it
was the end of march or early it's been
a while yeah so so tell us about one
degree of scandal oh thanks okay so you
know i've had this in mind for a long
time so i have this one degree brand
where we just are at we have access to
so many people in the entertainment
world the sports world to tell their
story so if you see the guy with his
with the glasses that's kato kalyn so
everybody that remembers the oj simpson
saga cato was living in the guest house
you know he was the man in the middle of
it he was the star of the oj trial and
cato was a friend of mine and i thought
there's no one more associated with
scandal than cato kalin right so i
wanted him as my co-host and we've
started this podcast we're two months
into it and it's really fun so it's
called one degree of scandalous and we
talked to the people that were directly
in the most high profile visible coolest
craziest scandals there were i'll give
you a couple examples remember when
ariana grande went in and licked those
donuts at that donut shop in riverside
this was in july of 2015. we have the
donut shop owner but when you hear the
back story right or two weeks ago on our
show we had one of the guys that grew up
with everybody with death row records
right he has the most amazing story
about how he basically saved tupac's
life before tupac was tupac and now he's
involved in championship rings he just
did the rams ring this past sunday we
taped our new episode it's going to be
incredible we have the pastor that just
married jen and ben so we were finding
out did he tip what did they pay with
you know was this a hostage situation
did he bring her in uh and we're all
over the o.j and people pat i found are
so fascinated with the oj simpsons yeah
they just can't get enough of it on our
first show cato holds up the key that he
actually still has the keys
in rockingham so if you wanted a
diversion from the craziness of the
world one degree of scandalous with kato
kaelin and tom center you can get it
anywhere you get your podcast and on
youtube thanks for the plug can we put
the link below can we put the link below
description and chat and matt
if folks you're not you're not hard to
find i mean you're all over the place so
if guys want to find you
youtube for for better for worse i mean
yeah i'm i'm i'm everywhere but no black
rifle coffee is our coffee company and
um we have i think one of the greatest
missions out there for the size of the
company and um yeah if you want to watch
your crazy contents youtube by new york
times bestselling book whatever
but
whatever just
we have a marine in there
eric shout out to eric eric's like
listen man i read his book it's sick
it's awesome couldn't put it down so you
you you got fans everywhere i don't care
what you're doing so let's make sure we
put the link to the youtube channel
black rifle as well as the book uh gang
it was good to be back i think we're
doing podcasts again this thursday
thursday what are we doing thursday
representative joe walsh
representative joe very still you said
it's very serious yeah so it's going to
be interesting
all right sounds good gang i hope you
enjoyed it as much as we did if you did
give us a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye bye bye
thank you
you